I recently did a live stream on the
Netflix series about John Hunyadi, the
Hungarian hero who defied the Ottoman
Turks.
But because I went off on a number of
tangents, and because it's an important
topic, I decided to put together a more
concise and focused video, this one, to
address it. So, let's get to it. The
Hungarian-made 10-part series called The
Rise of the Raven premiered in 2025.
Now, being the author of a 35-page
chapter dedicated to Hunyadi's wars
against the Turks, and therefore having
an interest in the topic, I decided to
give the series a go. To say that it was
disappointing is an understatement. Let
us count the ways. For starters, the
series seems committed to a sort of
moral inversion.
Muslim Ottoman figures are regularly
portrayed as wise, humane, and moderate,
while Christians are depicted as greedy,
hypocritical, cruel, and or fanatical.
Yes, par for the course. Thus, in one
scene, Sultan Murad II
tells his son and future Sultan Muhammad
II
that he will show him the true face of
the Christian God. He then summons an
Italian merchant and asks him to build
boats to ferry the Turks into Europe.
The Christian is outraged and asks how
Murad could expect him, a good
Christian, to betray his faith. Murad
calmly offers him a vast sum of gold.
The Christian instantly changes his tune
and complies. In another scene, a
Serbian woman who decades earlier had
been turned into one of Murad's
concubines is finally released. She
returns home and seeks refuge in a
convent, asking to be admitted as a nun.
The head nun agrees, but only in
exchange for gold.
Later, when the Turks advance, and
although the concubine turned nun had
been a model resident, the uncharitable
nuns expel her for being, quote, "the
devil's concubine." In yet another
scene, Sultan Murad arrives at Vlad II's
Second's
and is horrified by the sight of impaled
victims.
He orders them to be put out of their
misery and scolds Vlad for his
barbarism.
The moral contrast is unmistakable. The
Muslim ruler is compassionate and
civilized. The Christian prince is cruel
and savage. There's only one problem. Uh
there's no evidence that Vlad the
Second, not to be confused with his son
Vlad the Third, ever impaled anyone.
Whereas Turkish use of impalement is
well attested. Furthermore, it was Murad
who engaged in barbarous customs, such
as when he insisted on holding a banquet
in the midst of thousands of dead and
dying men, Muslims and Christians, on
the fields of Varna in 1444. This
pattern, Muslim restraint and Christian
brutality, permeates the entire series.
Here's another serious problem. Although
the series is set in 15th century
Hungary, a deeply religious world by any
measure, its characters speak, think,
and behave like modern seculars.
Religion is treated by everyone as
superstition, something Christians must
pretend to, but really don't care about.
This applies to Hunyadi himself.
A married father, he is portrayed as
sexually promiscuous.
He consorts with prostitutes, boasts of
having told a hundred women that he
loves them, and carries on a long affair
with an Italian woman. Needless to say,
there is zero historical evidence that
Hunyadi, who married his wife when he
was 25, ever betrayed her.
Interesting how a Hungarian series,
ostensibly celebrating a national hero,
goes out of its way to present him as
faithless to his wife. Hunyadi's
Christianity is also inverted. The
historical Hunyadi appears as a pious
man in the sources. Before the siege of
Belgrade in 1456, he wrote to the
Franciscan friar John Capistrano,
saying, quote, "Come hither to me that
the power of God may sustain the efforts
of men."
In battle, he would regularly invoke
Christ, encourage his troops, saying
things like, "Quote,
be of a stout heart, my dear sons. Put
your trust in Christ. Did he not die for
us? And should we then account it a
hardship to die for him? Be valiant then
and strive manfully." Even after Hunyadi
had contracted the plague in his defense
of Belgrade and felt his death draw
nigh, he begged his old comrade,
Capistrano, to transport him to the
local church for his final communion.
The Franciscan told him to rest. The
Eucharist be brought to him. Not so,
retorted the savior of Belgrade. It is
not meet that the master should come to
his servant. It is for the servant to go
and seek his lord. Then, although his
strength was failing, writes the
chronicler, he ordered himself to be
carried into church, where he made his
confession in the Christian way,
received the divine Eucharist, and
surrendered his soul to God in the arms
of the priests.
By the way, none of this piety is
evident in the series. That Hunyadi,
two-dimensional, promiscuous, and
cynical towards Christianity, bears
little resemblance to the man described
in contemporary resources. One cannot
help but wonder whether this is an
attempt to make him relatable to, or
simply to indoctrinate, modern
audiences.
The moral distortion of Hunyadi's
character is matched only by the erasure
of his greatest achievements. For all
its obsession with invented sexual
scandals, the series completely omits
Hunyadi's most remarkable feat, the long
campaign.
During the harsh winter of 1443 to 1444,
Hunyadi did the unthinkable. He took the
offensive against the Turks, penetrating
deep into Ottoman territory under brutal
conditions, accomplishing what many
thought impossible. Due to its
importance and its sheer audacity, I
devoted an entire section of my Hunyadi
chapter to this campaign.
Yet, the series completely ignores it.
Apparently, scenes of winter warfare and
the liberation of Christian territories
could not compete with yet another
unsupported sex scene. Apparently real
and inspiring heroism rooted in
Christian faith, endurance, and
sacrifice must never be depicted lest it
compromise the many fake scenes of
sexual depravity that the series is
trying to normalize. If most Christian
characters, including Hunyadi, are
portrayed as anything but Christian, the
very few Christians who do appear
sincere about their faith are among the
most unsavory characters.
This too is par for the course if you're
familiar with movies that deal with the
medieval era. For example, a papal
legate who accompanies Hunyadi before
the Battle of Varna is depicted as a
sincere Christian.
However, rather than celebrating the
liberation of Orthodox peoples from
Ottoman rule, he savagely and
sadistically tortured them for refusing
to convert to Catholicism. In fact, the
historic sources record quite the
opposite, that the long-oppressed
Orthodox Christians went, quote, wild
with joy.
That liberator and liberated reconverted
the mosques back into churches and gave
thanks in them. And that the Orthodox
eagerly joined forces with the Catholics
against the common enemy, Islam. In the
words of one historian, quote, the
Balkan peoples became excited by the
hope of their liberation, which appeared
close as Hunyadi's army advanced. The
local population welcomed them
everywhere with gifts and food so that
the soldiers hardly used the supplies
they had brought along.
The camp of the king, the Catholic king,
became filled with Bulgarians, Bosnians,
Serbians, and Albanians.
According to the sources from that time,
the population was very much set against
its Turkish oppressors. Instead, the
series, echoing modern clichés, has even
that most sadistic of characters, Vlad
the Second, say that Ottoman rule is
preferable because the Turks at least
allow Orthodox Christians to practice
their faith. So, despite recorded
history, including the Turkish massacre
and enslavement of millions of
Christians throughout the 15th century,
the series would have you think that
Muslims were tolerant, certainly in
comparison to those cruel Christians.
Incidentally, the series extends even
more distortions and outright lies to a
lesser character, yet one whom I also
wrote another entire chapter on, Vlad
the Third, known as the Impaler, the son
of Vlad the Second, is portrayed less as
a historical ruler and more as a gothic
monster, closer in fact to Bram Stoker's
Dracula than to a 15th century defender
of the faith.
In one scene, while raping a woman, he
bites her neck and drinks her blood.
How so very predictable.
Needless to say, there's no historical
evidence for that sort of behavior.
Vlad is also depicted as being a loyal
henchman of Sultan Muhammad the Second,
sadistically urging on Ottoman troops
and whipping them at the siege of
Belgrade until the supposedly more
merciful Muhammad relieved him of duty.
Back in the real world of recorded
history, Vlad the Third was a bitter
enemy of Muhammad the Second.
And during the siege of Belgrade was
allied with, not against, Hunyadi and
tasked with defending the eastern
frontiers against the Muslims.
The connection between Radu, Vlad's
younger brother, and Muhammad the Second
is also distorted in a way to improve
the image of the conqueror of
Constantinople and scourge of
Christendom.
In the series, Radu appears as the
homosexual partner of Ali, Muhammad's
brother.
After Ali is killed, Radu becomes
Muhammad's ally, though with no
homosexual relations.
Meanwhile, back in the real world of
recorded history, not only was Muhammad
a notorious pedophile and bisexual, but
it was he, not his brother Ali, who
forced Radu into a homosexual relation.
Why alter these details?
On the one hand, the series is willing
to attribute sexual depravity to
Christian figures, even when there's no
evidence of it. On the other hand, it
refrains from attributing such depraved
behavior to Muslim figures,
even when there's an abundance of
evidence for it. Weird how that goes,
no?
Taken individually, any one of these
changes might be dismissed as artistic
freedom. Taken together, they form a
pattern that is way too difficult to
ignore. Rise of the Raven does not
simply dramatize history. It rewrites
it, which is apparently the whole point.
Social engineering presented as
entertainment. Christian figures are
stripped of piety, morality, and heroism
before being burdened with hypocrisy,
cruelty, and sexual corruption.
Turkish rulers, by contrast, are
repeatedly humanized, if not moralized.
Their actual historical personalities
and behaviors, soaked in sadism and
blood, are completely whitewashed.
Moreover, the medieval world, in all its
religious intensity and civilizational
conflict, is replaced with a familiar
modern template. Christian faith is
fanaticism, sexual restraint is
repression,
traditional heroes must be made flawed
and recognizably modern ways.
What is lost in the process is not only
historical accuracy, but the very
mindset that animated the age being
portrayed. Calm down, man.
In the end, the greatest casualty of the
series is not any single figure, but the
past itself, reshaped to validate
present sensibilities, rather than to
illuminate a world that was, in many
ways, profoundly different from and
offers important lessons to our own.
Bring back
the fire.
and the righteous